Can the right machine used to help with testicular pain or any pain for that matter?
Always with anything you always want to ask the question
Why right so if I have testicular pain or if I have you know kidney pain or if I have pain in my big toe
You always got to go why and you want to treat the why so if I don't have let's say if I don't have
You know if I know I have cancer
Testicular cancer. That's why I have pain. Okay, then that's the reason why I just need to decrease the inflammation
Can I use the right programs or pain? Sure. Can I use the right programs for inflammation? So whatever you have paid
some of the inflammation programs may be
more appropriate to use
so
Because
Lots times paid is going to be caused from inflammation. Now you also are asking the question why why do I have inflammation too? So
You always want to treat the reason why so if I am pain in an area you want to try to figure that out if it can't be explained
through
Something that you know you have going on you may want to dig into
To see what is
Actually happy happening remember whatever I've paid in any area in your body. It can be referred paid
So let's talk about testicular pain. It's
Interimated by my don't know as think
Maybe the pure dental nerve
It's coming out of your
lower lover or sacral area
Could the paid be referred because I have prostate cancer because I have
So if I have paid due to something going on and I got that that
A favorite fiber is going to fire back into my spinal cord where it crosses my spinal cord and sitpses to an ascending
A favorite fiber and it's going to go up to my final low
Neurology there. It can fire back and you can get referred pain. That's a referred pain is somewhere else in the body
So you can get a referred pain that
Is has nothing to do with the area where you're having pain
So investigating why you have pain is important because it might not have anything to do with your testicle
Or your big toe or your gut. It could be how you could be getting referred pain from something else
So you want to investigate that. That's why you
You know you do
Labs and scans and x-rays and things like that to make sure you don't have something right on
And if let's say you have really bad testicular pain and
Your cancer that you're dealing with is like I don't let's say liver cancer
It doesn't mean you can't have more one thing going on at the same time
So it'd be good to get that examined. We have a number of patients
That might even be on this call that have
Two or more different cancers
So now we have metastasized
Cancer let's say if you have breast cancer metastasized to your lung it's still breast cancer. We should go to have two different cancers
We have several patients that have two different cancers lung cancer and breast cancer totally different cancers
unrelated to one of them so
But also you can have other things going on other thing that can cause testicular pain pain is blockage
That can cause inflammation
Um, so you know what and you want to get those things checked out to make sure you're not
Just using the right machine to cover up something also, you know what I use
Any nutrition or any natural things to cover up like your body's trying to tell you
So you want to investigate
to the cause